what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich for us
trying to get a lunch money right i'm
here with pelina
papayano what up watch myself watch my
blog
go to blockbuy.com you can use their
products they
have a crypto chain where you can buy
and sell crypto
with no fees you can deposit crypto take
out a us dollar loan get your crypto
cloud
or you can earn up to 8.6 apy in an
interest bearing account they're also
coming out with a credit card and that
credit card is going to be
awesome because you're going to swipe it
and they're going to pay you
back not in cash not in airline miles
but in bitcoin everybody trying to get
some bitcoin so
go to blockbuy.com get an account and
get ready to earn
what up um well hi guys uh first of all
special shout out to the person who was
walking his dog this morning
who said hello because he saw us in
lunch money hello
okay uh cryptocurrency tax automation
firm taxpayer raised 100 million dollars
in series a funding round
led by crypto investment fund paradigm
and tiger global
guess who else participated our friend
here you want to tell us about
tax bit 100 million dollars let's roll
tax bid basically they go to the
exchanges they say hey you guys need to
issue 1099 forms we can help you do that
we'll automate it
then also what they're going to say to
the exchanges is we can also do
real-time analytics so we can tell
people hey her tax loss harvesting
purposes you should sell this asset you
should do this
to better your portfolio they then went
to uh the government and they said hey
go
you guys have this stuff as well and
then on top of that they're going to
consumers and they're saying hey
shouldn't you go ahead and get your
taxes prepared so
if you taxed me to do your crypto taxes
this year you should go to taxbid.com
invite slash pump taxbid.com
invite slash pop if you go there you get
10 off all your crypto
taxes block tower capital crypto
industry investment firm has received
investments from billionaire hedge fund
mark what last week and jay christopher
oh god giancarlo
the former chairman of the crew oh okay
the former chairman of the commodity
futures trading commission
all these big names are entering crypto
nah my my guy chris john carlos
he's been encrypted he's known as crypto
dad he used to be the cftc chairman
he is the man uh i actually am a
massive massive fan of his i've had a
chance to talk to him a couple times i
am so
very impressed okay keep going i'm in a
rush
today paypal is said to be in the
process of buying curve a technology
firm that powers a secure storage of
cryptocurrency
according to three sources it's not
really confirmed but what if paypal
buys this thing what what happens just
further
this is this is no this is classic
nonsense one for uh one place in uh in
our uh israel is reporting is between
200 300 million dollars some in the u.s
500 million dollars who knows i hate
when you're born
i'm not talking about the price i'm
talking about doesn't this
if this does go through for however much
doesn't it just solidify paypal's
stance on crypto oh yes their philosophy
yes
it ain't gonna matter it ain't gonna
matter uh the
writing is on the wall most of the
legacy incumbents they can buy up all
the things they want they can't
keep up with the pace of innovation all
right
square the financial payments run by
jack dorsey launched an in-house
bank that it says it'll allow it to
operate more nimbly
oh i like that word nimbly in an
increasingly crowded fintech market
are we going to be banking with square
now what kind of everyone wants to be a
bank
everyone wants to be a bank they got to
be a bank but listen here's the whole
thing that i love
jack dorsey one of the greatest
entrepreneurs of our lifetime he's
drastically underestimated everyone
uh doesn't really give him the respect
that he deserves he's built two
multi-billion dollar companies and he's
running both of them at the same time
in the public markets my guys the g he
gets bitcoins the only thing in this bio
he
understands the world we're going to
part of it is square in order for them
to survive
and thrive they need to have the banking
licenses they have it now but at the end
of the day
jack said it over and over and over
again there will be one native currency
on the internet that currency will be
bitcoin and we are
going that way let's roll oh okay
wealth tax time billionaire leon
cooperman
told cnbc on wednesday he believes rich
people would find ways to avoid paying
senator elizabeth warren's
proposed wealth tax if it was to become
law he also argued that there are better
mechanisms to raise federal government
revenue he said the idea has no merit it
is foolish
it is probably not even legal i mean
listen if you're a billionaire you
probably shouldn't be saying
this crazy stuff to everyone's like of
course you don't want to pay the taxes
right but as i said yesterday we do
not have a revenue problem we have a
spending problem
every year for the last eight years the
government has taken in
more federal income tax every year than
the prior year so literally every year
we're taking more and more and more and
more and more
on a dollar basis the aggregate amount
is more
the problem is that every single one of
those years as well the federal deficit
has gotten bigger and bigger and bigger
for the individual year so every single
year not only are we taking in more
revenue but we're actually
running a larger and larger deficit it's
a spending problem it is not a revenue
problem and these politicians
don't want to tell you that because
already president biden's been in office
but as i tweeted out last night
my guy and his administration found time
to bomb another country but they can't
help the small businesses and the
unemployed here in our own country
and so how much money did it cost in all
the intelligence gathering and all the
military operations from the defense
organization to go drop bombs on syria
how about we take some of that cash and
we will help some people here we don't
even need to print more money all we
need to do is stop spending money on
dumb [ __ ] and go here
cooperman said if the wealth tax passes
go out and buy yourself some gold
because people are going to rush to find
ways of hiding their wealth
do we think gold or do we think they're
going to rush to buy i hope they buy
gold
go buy gold the old rich people
go buy gold also also can we just
reflect on
how shiny my face all right come on what
else we got i got things to do
all right it's lunch money time hashtag
ask lm in the comments below
uh because i was rushed thanks to my
friend today i couldn't get a question
so i'll get a few tomorrow
but moist update moist counter
um day 14 of commenting on every episode
of lunch money
i really enjoyed hearing the elizabeth
warren rant she's a swamp creature in
its purest form oh no
it's moist without any doubt without a
doubt i would choose the lion king yes
it is a great film for people of all
ages and it teaches a good message about
maturity and settling down something a
young man such as myself
should take heed of jordan peterson has
done a good analysis of this movie i did
not realize that
hashtag moyesgang hashtag i'm used to
the word unleash the moisture
why don't you ever pull comments like
the guy above it who said avery sims
a pump that's a fire shirt i remember
which shirt i was wearing
but of course it was fire because i got
it on yo boys listen here's the deal
i appreciate you we're on day 14 90's
kind of far away we're going to see if
you're disciplined or not lying i think
that was actually the right answer is my
favorite can i ask a question
sure okay so my question for you moist
we're going to get real
real deep real fast ready if you say
moist and deep it's a little weird
what was
are you thinking of the question yeah
what was the most
formative event of your childhood that
you believe
has shaped you into who you are today
moist be careful with this
this is a perfect example of the
difference between she's over here
asking serious deep really thoughtful
questions and i'm out here like
yolo do you want waffles or pancakes
waffles uh please answer in the comments
below i would actually appreciate other
people's answers
as well see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends